EU environment ministers will exchange
views on way to tackle illegal shipments
of waste that endanger human health and
the environment in talks in Luxembourg
on October 14 around twenty five percent
of waste shipments enter Asia or Africa
from the EU are thought to contravene
international standards the waste is
also often carelessly handled or dumped
when it arrives The ministers will
debate how the EU might implement new
proposals including spot inspections
better training of inspectors and
requirements for suspects to provide
evidence that any way shipment complies
with the law the way whether the
proposals are flexible enough and fair
for all stakeholders standards on waste
shipments vary widely in Europe and
exporters of illegal waste tend to move
it from countries where the controls are
most lenient the ministers are also said
to discuss the UN climate change
conference in Warsaw next month the EU
is a major international actor in the
fight against global warming The
ministers will set out the main elements
of the EU stance on the climate talks
which run from the 11th to the 22nd of
November they'll focus on the proper
implementation of existing decisions and
on the road map to guide countries
toward a legal deal to cut carbon
emissions in 2015 which would enter
force after 2020 economy and finance
ministers will also discuss the climate
change conference when they meet the
following day also up for debate on the
agenda at the environment Council is a
compromise text to help the EU meet its
target for cutting carbon dioxide
emissions from new passenger cars the
union wants to reduce greenhouse gases
from new cars by eighty to ninety five
percent by 2050 compared with levels
from 1990 current policies are only
likely to result in a forty percent
reduction by then